schreibt jetzt in die kommentare soll
ich weggehen von der stadt ganz weit weg
und gar keine technik machen und mit
simon danner und sonic leben
oder soll ich in der stadt bleiben und
technik machen mit kommen und den ganzen
anderen also schreibt mir auf jeden fall
jetzt in die kommentare was ihr wollt
hey leute und herzlich willkommen
endlich mal wieder zu einer neuen folge
von minecraft megaprojekt ich bin zur
zeit endlich wieder aus dem urlaub
zurück schweiz vier wochen insgesamt weg
ich habe so wenig hochgeladen ich habe
mich wirklich wenig um youtube gekümmert
allerdings hat mir diese zeit gezeigt
dass sich das irgendwie alles auch so
ein bisschen vermisst habe weil
irgendwie manchmal als die 0 ab und
versetzte darum dachte ich mir so
irgendwie würde ich jetzt echt gerne
aufnehmen und nicht mit mega projekt
beschäftigen und andere sachen somit
reviews und zwar aber dafür habe ich
jetzt noch drei wochen ferien und
habsburg nicht damit alles zu
beschäftigen und so was nur dann kann
man sich jetzt erst mal drauf gehen
dann kam allerdings wieder die so die
sache dass sie mir grad alles erzählt
hat was so alles passiert ist es gab
streit zwischen dazwischen brockens am
sonntag herr wo bin ich also meine links
blabla es gab streit zwischen brocken
thums und evonik und es gab so alles
mögliche was richtig und nötig
eigentlich warten und dann habe ich das
video gesehen wo simon bei dingsbums das
alles kaputt gemacht hat bei den namen
haus was nicht simon schäfer sich
schiebt die man gar keine schuld ein
nur simon ist halt über die presse plate
gelaufen von da ist es ein teil simon
schuldt aber ich möchte ihnen nicht
jetzt irgendwie anklagen oder irgendwie
sowas und es stehen jetzt zur auswahl
hat dass das gummi oder dingsbums hier
waren wirtschaftspark genau und ich weiß
jetzt nicht wem ich was glauben soll ich
hab jetzt nur ein paar aufnahmen gesehen
und was alles die wollen jetzt auch
meine meinung dazu ein hören und die das
logische fazit ist halt wartezeit gleich
mal ich denke ja wahrscheinlich bei den
anderen weiter geguckt weil ich halt
wirklich wenig gemacht habe logische
fazit von den explosionen ist das was
sie da alles gleich seht oder halt doch
nicht seht ihr seht nicht aber das ist
das war madonnas haus hier und das ist
so unfassbar heftig
louis dahin sind noch so sachen also die
kann ich mich gleich noch abgreifen weil
es also das ist echt heftig und die
sache ist jetzt nur dass simon weil bei
simon ist auch eine menge weg explodiert
evonik und den dabei den halt das meist
weg es kommen bleibt in der stadt
die sind jetzt halt irgendwo anders hin
gezogen die sind 10.000 20.000 30.000
40.000 blöcke weg gegangen
durch die hölle durch muss natürlich 80
landes mir wurden andere schaaf geübt
wird kommt ich brauche keine schafe die
sind jetzt wirklich irgendwo anders hin
gegangen wo die keiner finden kann und
machen da ihr eigenes leben vanilla
minecraft ohne technik und da jetzt
meine sache an euch
wollt ihr dass ich mich jetzt hier mit
technik beschäftigen also eine query
aufstelle akan sachen zaubern meint
automatische monster vor allem eddie
kaye betapharm das alles habe ich mich
schon im singleplayer angeguckt und
könnte ich jetzt echt alles machen und
hätte doch wirklich bob dawn
die sache ist jetzt nur dass ich mit den
leuten die weggezogen sind das sagt
jetzt mal so ganz offen
mehr sympathisiere als viele hier sind
weil wir sind viel neu dazugekommen für
eni und tirol und zu alle mit denen ich
halte nicht viel zu tun hab ich habe
nichts gegen die die sind doch alles
super nett aber ich habe mir den halt
nicht so viel zu tun deswegen ist jetzt
die sache die ob ihr jetzt wollte dass
ich da hinten mit irgendwo hingehe und
einfach so mit denen erstmal lebe oder
soll ich mich erstmal mit technik
beschäftigen dann eventuell nachher
dahin oder einfach hier erst mal
weitermachen
also schreibt mir da einfach da am
besten eure meinung in die kommentare
das ist mir echt am allerwichtigsten das
was ihr findet weil ich hab jetzt lange
überlegt was ich machen soll und ich bin
echt selbst auf keinen entschluss
gekommen also ich bin mir echt nicht
sicher was ich will
und ja also na gut diese folge wird dann
sonne frage folge seien also schreibt es
alle jetzt in die kommentare schreibt
jetzt in die kommentare soll ich
weggehen von der stadt ganz weit weg und
gar keine technik machen und mit simon
danner und veronique leben
oder soll ich in der stadt bleiben und
technik machen mit kommen und den ganzen
anderen also schreibt mir auf jeden fall
jetzt in die kommentare was ihr wollt
ein haus die sache ist die ich wollte
meine query machen habe ich deine credit
habe ich nicht habe
die credit suisse oder panel maschinen
blog injection erstmal mit jetpacks habe
ich den chat blick wandert allerdings
klar bei mir hätte so electricals
jetpack schon so gut ich werde mir bald
auch wieder ein tag speck reinpacken
direkt nach dieser aufnahme werde ich
das mal duschen gehen dann werde ich
trainieren gehen dann werde ich mit
einem kumpel weiter
hier spielen also max der allerdings bei
facebook haben kein max oder wohnt
jemand alter wäre das ist mit dem
nämlich auf jeden fall mal auf das ist
egal
da wollte ich nämlich schon immer mal
dass einer dahin zieht ich könnte wetten
dass ist von rolle was der gute alte
sieht aber auch schon geil aus dass die
scheiße weg ihr alter west alter wer ist
das denn
also wie gesagt ich aber nichts
mitbekommen deswegen sagt jetzt nicht so
ihr könnt mir übrigens ihr könnt ihr
übrigens auch in die kommentare
schreiben
was eigentlich so alles passiert ist
weil ich habe halt sehr sehr wenig
mitbekommen und einfach mein von mss you
und mary-kate kilometer produziert
ich habe auch schon gedacht dass ich
jetzt auch mal einfach so ein paar
leuten was klaue also halt weil es nicht
sonst brauche ich drin und gefängnis
gibt weniger keine strafen ein ich
möchte eigentlich ganz legal
weitermachen übrigens ist hier ein penis
mit einem den kopf machen so als ob ich
mir doch keine kriege crafted hat man
erwischt ihn total wahnsinns ist also
schwer
im fortress form erhält transformers
maschinen blog induction fellners ich
hab ja 201 pulver
ich habe vor sorge macht ja wo sind
meine pipes eigentlich
da sind als und da ist dass die prärie
zwei elektrischen engines ich glaube ich
brauche sogar 33 eigentlich yz nur noch
ich glaube ich brauch sogar drei
electricals treiben wir die prärie hand
ich brauche einen glas blog das ist ja
heftig ich hasse das wenn einen die
einfachsten sachen fehlen aber diese
scheiße zu machen sind
fick dich spiel
ich habe einfach mal kein glas die
scheiße ich habe ich mal sand oder
fenstern
das kann eigentlich seit ich muss auch
im glas haben oder ich hab's tatsache
ich hab kein glas ich ziehe jetzt bei
irgendwem einfach ist das kalt ich muss
für seinen verfügten glas blog einfach
mal 1000 m in dieses wieder entworfen
ach man ja gut freunde um nochmal das am
anfang an zu sprechen schreibt mir in
die kommentare ob ihr wollt dass ich ein
outdoor werde mit ich bin dann rein
gefallen und eier zurückgehen kann man
nicht mal an die story wie dies konkret
solchen auto werden oder fahrzeug machen
also schreibt einfach in die kommentare
auf jeden fall sehr sehr dankbar weil
ich möchte dass euch entscheiden lassen
da noch eine weitere frage und zwar habe
ich ja schon mal live streams beitritt
stil gemacht werde ich auch in zukunft
mehr machen und die sache ist die dass
man das nicht
bei youtube hochladen muss wenn man
megaprojekt im livestream spielt die
sache ist jetzt nur die ich habe ja
schon mal live stream gemacht könnt ihr
mir ein programm empfehlen was so für
schlechte internetverbindungen gut ist
weil ich kann glaube ich nicht in hd
stream und so was alles aber das wird
auch mehr sein dass in der interaktion
mit mir habt während des megaprojekts
mir helfen könnte uns was alles also
könnt ihr mit programm empfehlen
irgendwie fast alles gibt so ein
livestream programm
ich habe auf jeden fall eine 16.000 der
leitung und das ist sehr schlecht
vielleicht krebs das ist wirklich ab
nummer chance also da könnten wir dann
einfach auch in die kommentare schreiben
ihr könnt mir einfach alles nicht kommt
dann eigentlich was sind das hier was
hochgenommen
auf jeden fall will kann er aus gut
was soll ich jetzt machen ich habe eine
query ich wollte mir drei electrical
engines machen weil zum besser geht und
dann schlechter so viele solarpanels
dran wie geht dann habe ich bei mir
zuhause halter nur 3 aber ich nehme auf
jeden fall so viel hin wie es geht und
ich weiß nicht ich glaube ich setze
erstmal unter ich glaub ich setze
erstmal unter mein haus die prärie weil
da kam mir erst mal keiner was clown
oder mache ich erstmal unter meinem haus
alles weg und dann werde ich übrigens
auch ein neues haus bauen und ich uns
noch keine idee aber das wird schon cool
denke die einem intakten hoeneß sagt
habe ich schon ein glas pisten nicht auf
pisten es irgendwo bitte keine pistols
hartnäckig bringen dieses spiel um
ich bringe es um wie wenig im voraus
habe ich der mitte produzieren aber
nichts geschafft
so egal pisten redstone
und ich hab nix alter diesel verfickte
spiel
ich brauche einfach eigentlich bäume ab
das ist mir scheißegal ist er direkt
neben dem grundstück von daher kommt ja
komm her kommen diese szene nicht direkt
gestorben ich kaufe mir übrigens bald
nochmal eine pc erweiterung dass es noch
flüssiger läuft zurzeit ist zum echten
bisschen zu viel am haken werde ich das
falsch eingestellte dorf zu wenig raum
zugewiesen habe oder irgendwie sowas
aber in den haag mit allen mitteln für
456 davon ist machen wir so ein paar
alter ich bin der scheiße das hab ich ja
total vergessen da rein zu gucken
hallo ich bin luca ich bin blöd ach man
ja gut glas kommt in der mitte tim kommt
oben hin
ach nee ich wollte erstmal pisten machen
so dass erst mal so viel wie geht da
oben kommt das team hin
am besten wenn ich mir endlich noch mehr
mache oder nämlich einfach respekt im
und noch mehr davon
und da noch ein bisschen glas raus
da oben kommt das tennis so da kommt das
glas hin und die tim geht ihm gut gehe
ich hoffe dass wir stärker da habe ich
auch noch zwei statt wie so gehe ich mit
holz und papier überall längst jetzt
noch stärker machen jetzt etwas ein paar
von diesen fakten gerät an
ich brauche recht einfach mal so einen
richtigen crafting table noch mal komme
ich mach mir also sandy bridge 1 234 so
table dahin
ein
wer hat die größten eier wert 22 wurde
ist was soll ich brauche bist doch der
wie man es von hier aus soll als einfach
darum ja gut
scheiße ich habe fast gar keinen mehr
ich brauche 88 leder glaube ich so ich
mache das erstmal ja kann man habe ich
als 32 16
scheiße jetzt habe ich hier viel mehr
achten ist ich brauche ich brauche noch
viel mehr drin
jetzt könnte ich mir nur einen machen
scheiß habe ich mich irgendwohin ich
muss sie bitten den jetzt nicht mehr mit
irgendwas anderes gutachten sind im
paket auch er toll trotzdem habe ich
dann zu wenig geht nicht auch silber
bitte kommen intensität in not im juni
kommt zweig noch kommt dann mal wieder
eigentlich müsste ich jetzt den stopp
machen so freunde ich habe jetzt fünf
electricals engines in der prärie und
die pipe das heißt ich werde die query
ihm wird eine vollkraft santana
stichwort landmark ich werde nirgendwo
also unter mein grundstück haltestellen
dann wird die unter meinem grundstück
erst mal alles abgraben
dass ich dann erstmal unter meinem
grundstück alles frei habe und dann baue
ich darüber erst mal mein haushalt so
jedenfalls wird die curry dann
angetrieben mit dem par lag titel
engines die golden transpower als zuviel
goldtransporter die transportieren dass
man oben meine kisten und ohne gekannte
vorne auf das schön
die transportiert das dann immer eine
küsten und dann ist unter meinem wunsch
erstmals weg das leid das ganze damit
lernt max ab stärke die ich mir noch
eben machen werde
landmark erinnert
redstone fackel und lapislazuli ich
sagen ich brauche aber nur vier
eigentlich immer 12345 so redstone
fackel
so 5
5 landmarks warte ich könnte ja
theoretisch schon mal aufstellen oder ja
kommt jungs dann können wir uns diese
folge mal dann stelle ich jetzt eben die
credit noch auf die elektiven engine die
golden transport pipes die landmark
solarpanel ich nehme noch zwei mittel
stellt einfach ein medium davon dran wo
sie diese werden
ich habe eine elektrische habe ich nicht
ein elektriker dorf und ich muss mir bei
glas kabel machen und einen schrank
lauda noch hierfür für die ganzen sachen
aber die quali ist ja quasi ein
tanklager in sich ich habe nun low
voltage ach das ist der unterschied
aber ach ich brauche acht solarpanels
und einen lv transformer ich habe mir
vor transform aber ich brauche acht von
den low voltage stellen na gut dann
nehme ich erst mal nur sechs von den
solarpanels dann können die beiden
artikeln die stetig wird wegen wieder
ran weil es eine scheiß aktion ich weiß
tut mir auch leid
so ich halt erstmal dran
da brauche ich dann allerdings ich mache
jetzt einfach so glas für sachen diamant
redstone glas für ich hasste glas geht
ja noch redstone
so 12 müsste ich erst mal reichen von
diesen kabeln und jetzt kommen wir eine
curry aufstellen unter meinem grundstück
die volketswiler viel enger als ich
dachte aber na ja wir können
ich brauche ich sitze hier die ganzen
leute hier sind und die ganze zeit mir
so scheiße aufs grundstück stellen und
zwar wird die prärie die muss ja dann
theoretisch nur die stelle ich einfach
mal auf diese höre dass es doch
eigentlich perfekt
das heißt die wurst die köder
die habe ich den die damals single also
ich brauche auf jeden fall erstmal strom
über die solarpanels solarpanels stelle
ich mir einfach acht mann das ist zu
wenig platz hier ärgerlich er gar nicht
ach man hat das aber ich gerade ihnen
wie voll doof
die gebe ich eine quelle überhaupt hier
erstmal dem strom als ich musik höre
hier hinstellen
die muss dann mit dem mittelberg
blättler verbunden sein
das heißt ich brauche eigentlich hier
jetzt noch so nährt blog stellt daran
die prärie drauf
brüssel das gitter was sie gemacht hat
es behindert achter darf ja nichts im
weg sein achtfach stimmt scheiße da muss
ich mich komplett durch gkn i ich kann
ich dir den abbauen
ja gut dann schlecht jetzt erst mal hier
unten rollen das macht jetzt endlich
auch keinen unterschied da darf halt
nichts im weg sein bei der caritas ist
ein bisschen ins boot
sodann stellt das jetzt erst mal hinten
rein stellen die fowler paar noten
nein nicht so stockfinster alter
aufnahmen geben wir so was schon viel zu
lange
das macht das erste mal hier so willst
du mich verarschen lernt marias leben
funktioniert hier
ach nee ich muss erstmal die landmark
setzen a stimmt stimmt den ball dreht
sich dann einfach einfach cryptic ramos
direkt davor stehen das heißt hier macht
es einfach mal hier
hier kommt noch einzelne fackel fackel
packe ich habe einen an der waffel würde
ihn kommt eine hin da hinten kommt auch
noch eine hin und schlagen auf den
gleich schauen wir genau hier auch die
behinderte kompakte drin
so
die steht ja auch auf dieser seite ich
bin sooo geil geil
es kommt hier der hin da kommt die
landmark in nicht du scheiße ich wusste
dass das kommt das werk und die kommt
jetzt anhört macht dass man da hinten
einfach hier ist es eigentlich perfekt
die muss jetzt nämlich wartet
die muss da hin
wieso generiert er den rest dann jetzt
also gut so da hat er jetzt das gitter
und da soll zur lissabon
das heißt die prärie muss genau wie vor
ben southall hat dein maul die sicht to
small als kommt hier ein elektriker
engine for hier und hier ich mach erst
mal 3 jetzt brauche ich diese glas für
burg halle verbunden da kommen jetzt
diese teile hier dran
und jetzt kommt hier
das wär's perfekten plan folgt ja kein
strom man richtig lief man man das ist
doch kacke da haben die da unten einfach
mal keinen strom
aha krieg die krise alter
ich brauche diesen in diesem zauberstab
ich hab nur noch einer feier auf [ __ ]
mann
ich krieg wisst ihr was ich glaube ich
jetzt einfach irgendwo runter ich hoffe
einfach dass jetzt irgendwie hier
richtig bin direkt neben ihrer klasse
luca kam noch ein paar blöcke weiter
hier müsste jetzt eigentlich perfekt
sein
komm schon ja der erste
es ist so eine scheiße arbeite gerne
mache also ich muss die gerade die
solarpanels freischaufeln damit die halt
auch unter der erde so [ __ ] [ __ ] wäre
der schritt bedeute nichts als weg auch
nicht gut die glasfaserkabel hält es aus
eine echte katastrophe hätten das nicht
ausgehalten
ok kommen die haben ja schon mal strom
dass er schon mal geil letzte mal
daneben
es war genau hier
der hier war überflüssig die relativ gut
also leute dann jetzt da die die
aufnahme dem ende nähert sag ich mal
schon mal dass am ende aber ihr könnt
mir in die kommentare schreiben ob
irgend welche livestream programme habt
und ob ich zu den auslauf outlaws
gehören soll oder ob ich hier erst mal
so ein bisschen daran werkeln soll einen
ganzen tag ich brauch leser - ticks mit
nein ich habe keine sticks mit und ich
habe auch glaube ich keine lämmer ich
musste mir noch immer haben wollte da
acht die kiste brauche ich auch noch in
die kiste nur scheiße drin ist ich hab
da noch kisten oder war da noch einen
test eigentlich müsste ich dann diamant
schätzt ihn stellen wir das so viele
sachen sein werden
ich werde nachher auch die ganze sache
dann sortieren und dann 24
hallo nachdem kein strom zwingen wenn
ich nur 'nen appel als es ist ich wollte
15 minuten aufnehmen dessen schüler 26
wer es jetzt nicht funktioniert nicht
irgendwie
also die werden auf jeden fall schonmal
angetrieben
ach so die curry macht das schon
will mich verarschen
stop stop
hey du sollst nicht das abbauen du
verdammte sei du sollst das mit den
landmarkt abbauen alter geistig
behindert ich hab das doch direkt daran
gestellt und da ist auch nichts im weg
oder so etwas im weg da ist nichts im
weg
er will die mich denn verarschen
das muss ich die landmark noch einen
höher setzen
aber ich glaube ich muss
oder macht das keinen unterschied was
jetzt gerade machen will wird mal so ich
glaube ich muss doch erst so dann mache
ich so so das ist jetzt ein gebiet so
und das soll die kreml jetzt abbauen
weil da setzt jetzt die query vor credit
suisse auszeit auf junk rating bar to
small hat ein schnauzer alter dies doch
perfekt das ist zu groß
mach das mal so ein bisschen kleiner
hier sondern setzt sich jede landmark in
eine firma die beiden
so
ohnehin so da oben da ist auch nichts im
weg oder so das klappt ja alles gegen
biene details wenn jetzt die curry
abbauen 15 thema nicht dann mache jetzt
erstmal stoppen denn funktioniert
deshalb gut es funktioniert nicht wie so
funktioniert das nicht funktionieren
dass da hin wenn ich da hinten dran
setzen
es funktioniert nicht richtig
hey
junge ich hab das gar nicht alles
schreibt mir das mal bitte in die
kommentare also im singleplayer das
immer funktioniert mit den ganzen sachen
ich weiß nicht was ich falsch gemacht
habe
also hier ist das gitter was ich
erzeugen will hast du dir die da hinten
sind es irgendwie auch alle abgefallen
oder wie
dann müsste es eigentlich hätte die
query aber musste aufbauen müssen
man ist das scheiß sollte ach man ja
leute also ich weiß nicht warum es gar
nicht funktioniert schreibt mir das am
besten einfach in die kommentare wieso
funktioniert das hier hinter jetzt auch
gar nicht die mutter rief hey leute ich
bin so verwirrt schreibt mir das einfach
in die kommentare warum funktioniert das
termin ist jetzt beim nächsten mal
wieder ciao